[Music]
[Applause]
the reason I'm here is to introduce to
you Ashley - it's just really important
to be who you want to be hey there
I'm Ashley - it's so great to meet you
Rachel here - I'll be here for me I'll
be here for you she doesn't understand
how fragile all business you think I
should up the dose knock them dead
yourself getting so hard to keep doing
this
that's really the app says that we need
to do it within the hour it's peak
fertility to say so much I don't know if
I can I'll well know what I'm going
after I leave here
[Music]
another thing about you sometimes you
just sort of go away sure
I love you too is something going on
something going home that's what I said
not one minute nothing is going on
about
[Music]
now once more return your attention to
the Perth Airport
yeah terminal 3 did you work in that
place smithereen yeah the Sat Nav sound
an accident coming up you mind if I
follow an alternate route it showed me
your mind
I wonder simply what
smokin
calmly and without judgment
[Music]
you
you